for President George HW Bush will soon
lie in state in the US Capitol flags at
federal buildings in Washington and
across the country will fly at
half-staff for 30 days our last farewell
to a president happened 12 years ago
after Gerald Ford died one of the planes
used as Air Force One arrived in Houston
yesterday it will be renamed special air
mission 41 when it flies mr. Bush to
Washington this afternoon the
president's service dog Sully
said goodbye last night a Bush family
spokesman tweeted this photo with the
caption mission complete bianna
golodryga is leading our coverage from
Houston she's outside st. Martin's
Episcopal Church where mr. Bush
worshiped in his final years beyond good
morning John and Nora good morning to
you it's a sad day for the country
especially sad for the city of Houston
which lost two of its most famous
residents all within just a matter of a
few months the late president will be
flown to Washington in just a few hours
from here in Houston yesterday I spoke
with the man who's been a spiritual
guide in mr. Bush's life for the last
decade he was there for the final
moments of both president and mrs. Bush
he told me the president's final moments
were like something anyone would want
surrounded by loving family and friends
and ready to leave this world for the
next I see history is a book with many
pages today another page in the history
book turns in each day we fill a page
with acts of hopefulness and meaning as
the nation honors one of the country's
most devoted public servants it's lost
not just for Houston it's lost to our
nation and it's lost to the world family
pastor dr. Russell Levinson jr. was with
President Bush at the very end you were
fortunate enough to be there for not
only Barbara's passing but also the
president's can you talk about that
moment Friday night it was a as it was
with Barbara a comfortable dignified
graceful and in many ways wonderful
moment this is America
he built a life around the theme of his
most
famous speech brilliant diversity spread
like stars like a thousand points of
light and a broad and peaceful sky and
shown as a young Navy pilot in World War
two serving decades in government from
CIA director to vice president to the
nation's highest office so help me God
less than a year into his term the
Berlin Wall fell and a decisive victory
for the US military in the Gulf War led
to high approval ratings but he was
criticized for not removing Saddam
Hussein from power while some point to a
broken campaign promise read my lips
as one of the reasons he was a one-term
president and this man who might always
liked and respect it and then run
against and a painful campaign in some
ways I literally came to love putting
his love of the country ahead of
politics as a former President George HW
Bush reached across the aisle his
humility and his decency reflects the
very best of the American spirit even
offering comfort while he himself was
ill to former Vice President Joe Biden
whose son Beau was in a Houston hospital
he said I just came to welcome you to
Euston and to tell you how I feel about
because most of all George Herbert
Walker Bush cherished family after both
Jeb and George were elected governor on
the same day I was flying home to
Houston from from Florida and I said to
borrow this a happiest day in my life
and she said what about the day we were
married I said that was a nice day to
president and mrs. Bush had an
unshakeable bond even after her death he
missed his Barbara and say he loved her
he loves her and in his last moments
close friend and former Secretary of
State James Baker said the resident
spoke his final words in a phone
conversation the very last words he
spoke were spoken to George W Bush
President Bush 43
had told him how much he loved him that
he would seem on the other side and 41
said I love you too
this is a family so full of love Baker
said the morning before the president
died he opened both of his eyes looking
at a Secretary of State and asked Jim
where are we going
secretary Baker who called President
Bush jefe Spanish for chief said well
jefe we are going to heaven to which the
president replied that's where I want to
go and Norah in a conversation that I
had with Reverend Levinson he said a few
months back he'd been speaking with
President Bush about his passing and
about the afterlife
and President Bush obviously wanting to
be reunited with Barbara also wanting to
be reunited with the three-year-old
Robyn who they died at the age of three
from leukemia and he asked Reverend how
old do you think she'll be Reverend said
I don't know but it'll be a beautiful
moment Nora was so touched by that
bianna thank you so much and even
hearing about James Baker and the final
moments that he spent with his longtime
friend they had met on the tennis court
many moons ago and he had run all of
Bush's campaigns and talking about
rubbing his hands and his feet in the
final moments yeah to be there with your
closest friend and your family around
you and remember Barbara Bush she had a
sip of bourbon when she was good going
that kind of love a life lived this way
that is the reward is to go that way
surrounded by family and friends